das US-Militär hat verkündet dass sie
dieses Jahr angeblich die bedeutendste
Demonstration von Stromübertragung via
Luft durchgeführt haben und da haben wir
uns gewundert denn die Technologie gibt
es schon seit 130 Jahren und ist aus
gutem Grund noch immer nicht marktreif
wir sind bisher nicht weiter als 1,54 km
gekommen mal abgesehen von einer 148 km
Übertragung von aber gerade mal 20 Watt
was ausreicht um immerhin ein Handy
aufzuladen aber auch nicht viel mehr als
das also was ist hier passiert ist die
Militär wirklich ein großer Durchbruch
gelungen genau darum geht es jetzt
[Musik]
kleine Geräte wie zum Beispiel Handys
können wir schon seit ein paar Jahren
ohne Kabel laden wir legen es einfach
nah genug an eine kontaktlose
Ladestation und schon wird es mit
energieversorgt das funktioniert über
Induktion also über ein
elektromagnetisches Feld für große
Distanzen taugt das aber leider nicht
und alternative Methoden sind noch immer
nicht marktreif trotz 130 Jahren
Forschung selbst apple hat sich hier
dran vor ein paar Jahren die Finger
verbrannt dieses Ding hier kennt ihr
bestimmt noch aus dem Schulunterricht
die Tesla Spule von 1891 ist im Prinzip
nichts anderes als eine Apparatur um
Strom ohne Kabel zu übertragen Nikola
Tesla konnte so eine Glühbirne aus rund
30 Metern Entfernung zum Leuchten
bringen seine Vision ein weltweites Netz
von Türmen die über die Luft jeden
Winkel der Erde mit Strom versorgen blöd
nur dass er bei dem Glühbirnen versucht
den dynamode des örtlichen
Stromerzeugers durchbrannte und so die
gesamte Stadt Colorado Springs in den
Blackout schickte
trotzdem System wurde seine Idee nicht
aufgegeben ein Nachbau von Teslas Türmen
steht in der Nähe von Moskau an einem
fast geheimen Ort ein deutsches
Medienteam das sich 2016 auf die Suche
nach ihm gemacht hat bestätigte die
Existenz dieser Türme auf dem russischen
Areal gäbe es zwei Spulen die durch
einen Magnetfeld Energie in Form einer
Art Blitz übertragen könnten marktreif
ist der Versuchsaufbau aber leider nicht
der Blitz dauert nur 15 Mikrosekunden
kostet aber 15.000 Euro wie viel Energie
dabei übertragen wird wissen wir leider
nicht aber ich schätze mal dass es
leider nicht so effizient ist und das
ist generell eines der Hauptprobleme von
kabelloser Energieübertragung selbst
wenn man zum Beispiel Handys direkt auf
Ihre wireless charging stations legt
also nur eine sehr kurze Strecke
überbrücken muss benötigt das Laden hier
teilweise bis zu 47% mehr Strom als das
Laden per Kabel das Problem ist also
einfach naja die Physik denn wenn ich
Energie übertragen möchte brauche ich
für den Transport irgendeine Art
elektromagnetische Welle
bzw ein Teilchen also ein Photon einmal
diese Quantenphysik prinzipiell kann ich
also alles nehmen von Röntgenstrahlung
über sichtbares Licht bis hin zu
Radiowellen in der aktuellen Forschung
wird vor allem mit Mikrowellen und
Lasern experimentiert und das ist echt
mega spannend denn hierfür nutzt man
jetzt ganz andere Technologien als die
Spuren so wie man nun schon seit Jahren
nach besseren Ansätzen für kabellose
Energieübertragung Sucht werden auch
Lösungen für die Bekämpfung des
menschengemachten Klimawandels dringend
benötigt und damit kommen wir zum
Sponsor des heutigen Videos nämlich der
klima-app falls ihr die App noch nicht
kennt ihr könnt dort zum Beispiel eure
CO2-Emissionen ausgleichen euch aber
auch Tipps für ein nachhaltigeres Leben
holen und gemeinsam mit euren Freunden
etwas gegen die Klimakrise tun beim
offseting von CO2 werden zum Beispiel
eure monatlichen Beiträge in eine
Vielzahl an Umweltschutzprojekten
investiert darüber hinaus habt ihr in
der klima-app auch die Möglichkeit euch
ausführlich über weitere Möglichkeiten
zum Klimaschutz zu informieren es gibt
zum Beispiel eine eigens produzierte
Videoreihe euch mit hilfreichen Tipps
für eine nachhaltigeren Alltag versorgt
außerdem spannend ihr könnt über die App
eurem lokalen Abgeordneten im Bundestag
schreiben und so ganz direkt mehr und
schnelleren Klimaschutz fordern denn die
Politikerinnen und Politiker dort haben
den längsten Hebel wenn ihr beim
Einrichten der App unseren Code benutzt
dann unterstützt sie damit auch noch
unsere Videos und können gleichzeitig 10
extra Bäume spenden gebt dafür einfach
den Code dr Watson in der App ein und
falls ihr euch noch nicht ganz sicher
seid ob die App wirklich hält was sie
verspricht kann ich euch vielleicht
dieses Video hier empfehlen da haben wir
uns ganz kritisch mit der App und dem
Thema CO2 offsetting auseinandergesetzt
insgesamt halte ich aber jede Form von
Aktivität und von gutem Willen für super
und deswegen hier noch mal vielen vielen
Dank an alle die sich die App bereits
heruntergeladen haben um einen
Unterschied zu machen und damit zurück
zum Thema also ein moderner Ansatz für
kabellose Energieübertragung sind
Mikrowellen und Spoiler mit denen hat
auch das US-Militär sein Experiment
durchgeführt mit Mikrowellen kommen wir
ziemlich und durch die Atmosphäre egal
ob sie horizontal zu Erdoberfläche oder
aus dem Weltall zu uns herabgesendet
werden gerade letzteres ist übrigens
extrem spannend dazu später mehr die 1
mm bis mehrere hundert Meter großen
Radio und Mikrowellen werden von den
verschiedenen Atomen in der Luft kaum
aufgehalten es gilt auch für Wolken und
Regen dadurch ist der Energieverlust
dieser Wellen unterwegs gering und sie
funktionieren unabhängig vom Wetter der
Haken an der Sache ist allerdings wegen
ihrer großen Wellenlängen braucht man
sehr große Empfänger am anderen Ende die
hatten in den bisherigen Experimenten
durchaus 24 Quadratmeter bis mehrere
Kilometer große Flächen aber gut dann
eben Laser dessen Wellen sind deutlich
kleiner Sender und Empfänger können also
ebenfalls deutlich kleiner sein mehr
noch man könnte bestimmte Laser sogar
auf bereits existierende
Photovoltaik-Anlagen richten die sie
dann in elektrischen Strom umwandeln so
verursacht die Technik deutlich weniger
kosten
doch Laser brauchen eine klare
Sichtlinie und verlieren unterwegs mehr
Energie an die Atmosphäre als
Mikrowellen das heißt bei Regen und
Wolken gibt es keine oder zumindest
weniger Energie zusätzlich ist die
Umwandlung von optischen Licht in
elektrische Energie sehr verlustreich
viele Studien zitieren hier eine
Effizienz von insgesamt um die 10% für
die Energieübertragung mittels Laser das
Allerbeste was wir gefunden haben sind
37% Effizienz das heißt 63 bis 90% der
Energie gehen im Laufe der Übertragung
an unterschiedlichen Stellen einfach
verloren bei den mikrowellen sind es
hingegen im besten Falle nur 15% Verlust
ein Effizienz von 85%
und dann gibt es noch den Punkt
Gesundheit man kann nun mal keinen
beliebig starken Laserstrahl auf eine
Gegend richten in der sich Menschen und
andere Lebewesen befinden das vertragen
wieder unsere Haut noch unsere Augen
außerdem haben starke Laser Waffen
Potenzial was diplomatisch schwer vor
der internationalen Gemeinschaft
durchzusetzen ist auch Mikrowellen kann
man nicht in beliebiger Intensität
einfach so durch die Landschaft senden
das heißt alle kabellosen Strom
Übertragungstechnologien sind limitiert
durch die gesetzlichen Maximalwerte dies
für den jeweiligen
strahlungsfrequenzbereich gibt und all
diese Probleme sind leider schwer zu
beheben es ist wirklich einfach Physik
forscher arbeiten an besseren Konvertern
von Mikrowellen also Lichtenergie in
elektrische Energie und umgekehrt sie
versuchen die Bündelung der Strahlung zu
verbessern sie suchen den genau
richtigen Laser oder sie versuchen die
Hitze Abstrahlung zu kontrollieren und
so weiter doch die physikalischen
Grenzen machen diesen Prozess sehr
mühselig und langsam kein Wunder dass es
bisher an großen Durchbrüchen mangelt
heißt all diesen Gründen waren wir sehr
überrascht als wir die Meldung vom
US-Militär gesehen haben ihnen ist es
angeblich gelungen mit Hilfe von
Mikrowellen 1,6 Kilowatt über rund einen
Kilometer Entfernung zu beamen das sei
so die Pressemeldung die bedeutendste
Demonstration von kabelloser
Energieübertragung in fast 50 Jahren
aber wie krass ist das wirklich erstmal
zur Stromleistung mit 1,6 Kilowatt könnt
ihr nicht viel machen gerade mal so eine
kleine Waschmaschine betreiben oder rund
80 Handys parallel laden der aktuelle
Rekordhalter bei der Leistung ist ein
Transfer von 30,4 Kilowatt mittels
Mikrowellen also fast das 19-facher
damit könnte ich immerhin schon mein
E-Auto laden wenn auch nicht besonders
schnell die Distanz von einem Kilometer
hingegen ist echt nicht schlecht die
meisten bisherigen Versuche bewegen sich
im Meterbereich
rekordverdächtig ist aber auch das nicht
ein Experiment der NASA aus dem Jahr
1975 gilt mit 1,54 km als Rekordhalter
mit nennenswerter Rüstung ein Experiment
von 2008 auf Hawaii schaffte sogar 148
Kilometer hier war die Stromleistung die
am Ende wieder ankamen jedoch nur 20
Watt das erscheint mir etwas viel
Aufwand um dann am Ende nur ein Handy
damit laden zu können was beim jüngsten
Experiment des US-Militärs jedoch
wirklich neu ist ist die größte der
Geräte sie waren deutlich kleiner als
beim Rekordhalter Experiment aus 1975
klar die größe ist nicht alles aber wie
eben schon erwähnt war die Größe der
Geräte immer ein Hindernis für die
Übertragung mittels Mikrowellen also
zusammengefasst das Experiment ist schon
cool aber nicht der lang ersehnte
Durchbruch trotzdem geben die forschen
in die Hoffnung nicht auf der Aufwand
für ein bisschen Energieübertragung wie
er Luft ist groß aber teilweise sind die
Alternativen noch teurer in Neuseeland
beispielsweise arbeitet der zweitgrößte
Stromanbieter daran bald mittels
Mikrowellen Strom in abgelegene Orte zu
transportieren sie hoffen dadurch die
enormen Kosten für den Aufbau und die
Wartung der kabelinfrastruktur zu sparen
und auch für die erneuerbaren Energien
könnte die Technologie ein Segen sein so
lässt sich beispielsweise der Solarstrom
aus der Wüste oder der Windstrom von
Offshore Windparks durch die Luft an die
Orte senden wo er wirklich gebraucht
wird wir bräuchten keine Strommasten
mehr die irgendwelchen Leuten quasi im
Vorgarten herumstehen Satelliten und
elektroflugzeuge könnten wir ebenfalls
vom Boden aus endlos mit
Energienachschub versorgen auch die 17%
der Menschheit die aktuell noch keinen
Zugang zum Stromnetz haben könnten mit
Elektrizität versorgt werden vor allem
ermöglicht die Technologie aber die
Stromerzeugung an einem Ort zu dem ihr
nicht mal dann ein Kabel legen könnten
wenn wir wollten nämlich ins Weltall die
ESA die NASA Japan Boeing und viele
viele mehr sie alle setzen Hoffnung auf
Solarpanels die im All die Sonnenenergie
einfangen und zu uns auf die Erde senden
so könnten wir unabhängig von Wind
Wetter und je nach Technologie auch Tag
und Nacht Strom erzeugen den wir sonst
einfach gar nicht hätten und da gilt
dann gar nicht egal wie hoch die
Übertragungsverluste sind 10% haben oder
nicht haben Japan hat sich das Ziel
gesetzt in etwas mehr als 15 Jahren den
ersten solar-satelliten in Betrieb zu
nehmen Großbritannien arbeitet auch
daran china will sogar schon in sechs
Jahren das erste Solarkraftwerk im All
starten und ich sage beam mit down
Scotty aber drahtlose Strom Übertragung
ist nicht nur hilfreich zum Welt retten
es gibt schließlich einen Grund dass
gerade das US-Militär hier so eifrig
dran forscht und nicht nur die Amis denn
der Energie Nachschub für Militärbasen
und Truppen im Feld ist schwierig zu
organisieren und teuer wenn die Truppen
ihren Strom einfach von Satelliten aus
dem All bekommen könnten würde das die
Kosten deutlich senken kein Wunder also
dass die verschiedenen Militärs dieser
Welt sehr gerne eine funktionierende
drahtlose Stromübertragung hätten aber
gut was denkt ihr wird Nikola Teslas
Traum irgendwann war und wir können uns
komplett von Kabeln verabschieden oder
ist das alles nur Quatsch und die
Technik wird auf ewig nur ein
Nischendasein fristen schreibt es mir in
die Kommentare wenn es etwas aber es
gibt dann erfahrt ihr das auf jeden Fall
hier auf Dr Watson also abonniert gerne
den Kanal um das nicht zu verpassen und
bis dahin bleibt neugierig euer Cedric